[Music]  it's taken 6 000 years for nature to  carve these remarkable formations  the marble caves of chile chico are  located on a peninsula of solid marble  bordering a remote glacial lake that  spans the chile argentina border  the lake is fed by rivers coming from  several surrounding glaciers  as the glaciers melt and grow the waters  slowly carve out the marble leaving  behind masterpieces fit for a museum  these distinct bright blue waters are  caused by suspended particles from the  glaciers reflecting the blue part of  sunlight  getting to this location isn't easy it's  a long journey requiring a flight a 200  mile drive into the wilderness and a  boat ride just to get there  but it's worth it  the remarkable swirling patterns on the  cave reflect the lake's blue waters  changing with the water levels and the  season  nature truly is the greatest artist  you